bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat ce matin les sénateurs
examine en séance le projet de loi
organique relatif à l'application du 5e
alinéa de l'article 13 de la
Constitution c'est ce projet de loi qui
aurait dû être voté avant les auditions
d'hier des candidats proposés à la
nomination au Conseil constitutionnel en
effet si ce projet de loi est adopté ce
matin le Parlement pourra désormais
s'opposer aux nominations du président
de la République à condition que
l'addition des votes négatifs des
commissions représente au moins 3/5è des
suffrages exprimés voilà donc pour les
enjeux de cette séance bonne matinée à
tous sur Public Sénat l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion en 2e lecture du
projet de loi organique adopté avec
modification par l'Assemblée
nationale relatif à l'application du 5e
alinéa de l'article 13 de la
Constitution et du projet de loi adopté
avec modification par l'Assemblée
nationale relatif à l'application du 5e
alinéa de l'article 13 de la
Constitution la conférence des président
a décidé que ces deux projets de loi
feraient l'objet d'une discussion
générale commune dans la discussion
générale commune la parole est à
Monsieur Henri de rincour minist chargé
des relations avec le
Parlement bonjour
ministre madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président de la commission des lois
monsieur le
rapporteur messieurs madames et
messieurs les
sénateurs les deux textes qui vous sont
soumis aujourd'hui en 2è lecture doivent
permettre la mise en uvre d'une des
innovations les plus plus marquante de
la révision constitutionnelle du 23
juillet
2008 désormais vous le savez le
Parlement va pouvoir mieux contrôler les
nominations envisagées par le Président
de la République aux fonctions les plus
éminentes pour la garantie des libertés
ou la vie économique et sociale de notre
pays la procédure prévue à l'article 13
de la Constitution qui s'appuie sur une
audition des personnes proposées par les
commissions
compétentes permettra d'établir la
transparence et la pertinence des
nominations à venir je ne reviendrai pas
longuement sur le contenu de ces texte
que vous connaissez
parfaitement la discussion en première
lecture aussi bien à l'Assemblée
nationale qu'au Sénat a
indiscutablement permis de les enrichir
je tiens à souligner à cette occasion
que les commissions des lois des deux
assemblées ont effectué un travail très
important sur ces deux projets et je
veux saluer
l'investissement personnel des membres
des commissions et des deux rapporteurs
respectifs et en particulier Monsieur le
Doyen gellard ici au
Sénat le projet de loi organique
présenté par le gouvernement a retenu
une liste conséquente de 41 emplois ou
fonctions votre assemblée a ajouté trois
fonctions de responsabilité l'Assemblée
nationale en a ajouté quatre la liste a
ainsi été complétée en cohérence avec la
démarche qui avait prévalu pour son
élaboration la répartition des emplois
et des fonctions entre les commissions
permanentes paraî également arrêté en
deuxème lecture l'Assemblée nationale a
simplement tiré les conséquences du
remplacement par une ordonnance du 21
janvier 2010 de l'autorité de contrôle
des assurance et des mutuelles par une
autorité de contrôle
prudentiel son président le gouverneur
de la Banque de France se trouve en
effet déjà dans la liste des emplois et
inclus dans le champ de l'article 13
alinéa 5 de la
Constitution la deème lecture porte donc
essentiellement on l'aura compris sur la
procédure applicable par les commissions
permanente pour la mise en œuvre de cet
article
13 les deux assemblées se sont déjà
mises d'accord pour compléter le projet
de loi ordinaire et prévoir que le
scrutin doit être dépouillé
simultanément dans les deux commissions
concernées l'Assemblée nationale a
également inscrit dans la loi le
principe de l'audition par les
commissions permanentes des personnes
dont la nomination est proposée votre
commission des Lois vous propose
d'adopter également cette disposition et
le gouvernement s'en
félicite j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
souligner l'importance de ces auditions
qui à
permettent de garantir la qualité des
personnalités proposées en revanche
l'Assemblée nationale a rétabli
l'interdiction des délégations de vote
lors du scrutin destiné à recueillir
l'avis des membres de la commission
votre commission des Lois vous propose
de supprimer à nouveau une telle
interdiction le gouvernement prend acte
de cette divergence
d'appréciation mais le gouvernement
souhaite
néanmoins que les deux assemblées
puissent trouver un accord sur les
modalités de vote applicables à cette
procédure
originale cela permettrait au Parlement
d'aller au bout d'une réforme dont
l'objectif ne l'oublions pas et
d'accroître ses prérogatives
merci
bien la parole est à Monsieur Patrice
gellard rapporteur de la commission des
lois prés
bonjour madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous nous
retrouvons une nouvelle fois pour
discuter en seconde lecture cette
fois-ci de l'application de l'article 13
de la Constitution dans son 5e alinéa
sur deux textes le texte de loi
ordinaire de loi simple et le texte de
loi
organique un seul regret pour commencer
monsieur le ministre c'est qu'il est
bien tard pour adopter ces lois
organiques la Constitution a été
modifiée en 2008 nous 2010 18 mois pour
adopter une loi organique qui est
nécessaire et qui nous amène à procéder
à des nomination qui ne sont pas
conformes à l'article 13 puisque nous ne
pouvons pas procéder au vote qui est
prévu et que nous sommes obligé
d'attendre un certain
nombre d'éléments qui se résultent de
cette loi pour pouvoir procéder
conformément à la Constitution aux
nominations qui sont soumises à
l'audition des commissions compétente de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat ce que
je viens de vous dire à propos de la loi
de l'article 13 pourrait être dit pour s
d'autres lois qui sont toujours en
attente d'autres lois organiques le
Défenseur des droits le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature et tant
d'autres et il est pas normal que 18
mois après l'adoption de la modification
constitutionnelle on en soit toujours
dans l'attente de l'adoption des lois
organiques le Conseil d'État qu estime
toujours qu'il y a un délai raisonnable
entre l'adoption des décrets
d'application après la loi ordinaire ce
décret généralement est considéré comme
étant de 6 mois là on a vraiment dépassé
la dose cette remarque ét en fait j'en
viens au fond de l'affaire je vais
traiter naturellement dans ce dans cette
explication orale les deux lois en même
temps je vous rassure tout de suite sur
la loi ordinaire nous proposerons
d'adopter la loi ordinaire telle qu'elle
est mais nous ajouterons deux
amendements à cette loi ordinaire parce
que profitant de ce que nous sommes en
désaccord avec la loi organique il y
aura navette sur la loi organique et sur
la loi ordinaire donc ce que je vous
propose sur la loi ordinaire c'est de
l'approuver tel quel plus deux
amendements l'un qui consiste à ce que
les dispositions soient publiques
puisque ça a été le cas hier dans les
audition au Sénat comme à l'Assemblée
nationale il faudra donc que nos
règlements d'assemblée complète ce
dispositif pour savoir comment le
déroulement des auditions se fera mais
je proposeraiis donc un avis favorable
sur cette disposition et puis il y a un
un deuxième élément qui sera également
déposé en concernant la loi ordinaire
donc pas de problème sur la loi
ordinaire à mon avis alors maintenant
j'en viens à la loi organique nous
sommes maintenant d'accord sur l'article
1er et l'article 2 de la loi organique
il y a juste un petit problème qui s'est
posé effectivement mais le le ministre
l'a rappelé il a fallu que l'on supprime
une personnalité puisque d'abord
l'ordonnance de janvier dernier l'avait
traité donc on l'a supprimé de la liste
qui était initialement prévu bon pas de
problème sur ce point par contre nous
avons décidé en commission des lois de
ne pas voter conforme la loi la loi
organique pour une raison très simple
c'est que nous sommes en profond
désaccord avec avec l'article 3 qui a
été créé de toute pièce par l'Assemblée
nationale en effet le texte initial venu
du
gouvernement nous suffisait largement et
aurait dû nous suffire largement d'abord
première remarque l'article 3 amené par
l'Assemblée nationale m'amène à la
penser que cet article 3 transforme la
loi organique en loi intéressant et
concernant le Sénat
pourquoi parce que malgré la
jurisprudence récente du Conseil
constitutionnel j'en reviens aux
déclarations du Doyen Vedel concernant
la définition des lois organiques
concernant le Sénat à partir du moment
où une loi organique met en cause le
Sénat et l'oblige à faire des choses
particulières en l'occurrence réformer
notre règlement et bien ceementl la loi
organique devient une loi qui concerne
le Sénat et qui par conséquent ne peut
être adop
qu'avec accord des deux chambres et il
n'y a donc pas de possibilité de vote en
dernière possibilité de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est un premier point sur
lequel il faudra sans doute que le
Conseil constitutionnel statut si nous
n'arrivons pas à trouver un terrain
d'entente deuxème
élément on en vient au fond de
cette article 3 déposé par l'Assemblée
nationale ce qui me frappe ce sont les
motivations profondes de l'Assemblée
nationale qui ont été parfaitement
explicitées par un député Monsieur
Patrice Vercher qui dit sans ambage
c'est pas normal que maintenant qu'il y
a h commissions permanentes à
l'Assemblée nationale et 6 au Sénat que
l'une des commissions permanentes du
Sénat soit plus nombreuse que la
Commission permanente du même de la même
nature à l'Assemblée nationale donc la
crainte était que
une commission permanente en
l'occurrence c'est la commission des
affaires économiques qu'il faut citer
tel quelle de chez nous de l'économie
cette commission compte effectivement au
Sénat quelques membres de plus très peu
mais ce n'est pas ça à mon avis qui
risque de transformer les choses et
surtout ça va beaucoup plus loin parce
que la Constitution dans son article
27 déclare qu'une loi organique peut
établir les raisons pour lesquelles la
délégation est possible mais je rappelle
que la Constitution ne prévoit pas que
la loi organique puisse interdire la
délégation sauf un cas qui est prévu par
la Constitution elle-même c'est la Haute
Cour qui pourra se réunir éventuellement
pour non pas juger ce n'est plus un juge
pour destituer le président de la
République ou dans ces cas-là il n'y a
pas de délégation possible c'est prévu
explicitement par la Constitution
en d'autres termes par parallélisme des
formes aucune autre formule ne peut être
mise en place par une loi organique pour
interdire la délégation de vote j'ajoute
que le règlement de l'Assemblée
nationale prévoit la délégation de
vote une instruction du bureau de
l'Assemblée
nationale qui contredit à la fois la
Constitution la loi organique et le
règlement de l'Assemblée nationale a
prévu que la délégation de vote n'est
pas possible dans un cas lorsqu'il
s'agit de nomination je rappelle que la
nomination à tel ou tel emploi d'un
député ce n'est pas du tout la même
chose qu'une audition une audition on
auditionne quelqu'un qui va occuper une
autre fonction à la demande d'une
autorité le président de la République
pour l'essentiel des cas qui est
extérieur au Parlement lui-même nous ne
sommes pas en face d'une nomination nous
sommes en face d'une audition et par
cont il y a à mon avis dans l'article 3
une violation manifeste de la
Constitution c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous ne pouvons pas suivre
l'Assemblée nationale dans cette
direction et que je vous propose de
supprimer d'annuler cet article 3 dans
cette seconde lecture et c'est la
conclusion que je suis amené à prendre à
l'issue des travaux de la commission des
lois sur cet article 13 de la
Constitution
la parole est à Monsieur Pierre Fauchon
pour l'Union centriste pour 8
minutes madame la Présidente monsieur le
ministre chers collègues je ne
reviendrai pas dans le détail sur
l'innovation majeure et attendu un peu
longuement attendu comme l'a dit
Monsieur Géard tout à l'heure que
représente audition par les commissions
des candidats aux emplois de
responsabilités politique économique et
sociale dans la République j'avais déjà
largement développé cette question lors
de la discussion générale préalable à la
première lecture je rappellerai tout
d'abord mon attachement notre
attachement à cette réforme importante
qui marque un pas en avant consid ble
vers une meilleure association du
Parlement au choix des personnes dont
les responsabilités qu'elles assument
font des acteurs majeur de notre vie
publique et qui doivent pour cette
raison échapper au risque d'arbitraire
de tout choix personnel et ce met une
occasion de dire que ceux qui ont refusé
de voter cette réforme sont bien mal
placés aujourd'hui pour donner des
leçons à cette occasion et pour en tirer
néanmoins profit comme s'il l'avait voté
que je trouve toujours assez admirable
je dois le dire mais j'ai dit que je
trouvais ça admirable n'est-ce pas je
n'ai pas dit que j'ai trouvais ça
criticable j'ai dit que je trouvais ça
admirable je maintiens pour autant nous
devons pas ignorer qu'il s'agit d'un
domaine qui relève de l'exécutif ne
l'ignorons pas au sens où l'entendez
montesc et que nous devons nous garder
de tout excès dans cette extension des
attributions du Parlement cette
observation vont en particulier pour
caractère public des auditions je
n'ignore pas que c'est la pratique du
Sénat américain j'ai moi-même assisté la
guerre mais nous sommes pas en Amérique
et no Meur politique diffèrent
profondément je crains que la publicité
n'accentue le caractère politique ou
personnel de l'audition je suis heureux
de faire rire madame vorveau je savais
pas que c'était si gay mais je m'en
réjouis je ris avec
vous c'est pourquoi nous acceptons avec
la commission cette ouverture publ mais
non sans réserve et quelque sorte dans
un esprit d'expérimentation comme le
permet expressément à la Constitution
dans une disposition selon moi trop
rarement utilisé d'ailleurs comme l'a
rappelé notre rapporteur la seule
question qui reste en suspens est celle
des délégations de vote lors du scrutin
destiné à recueillir la vie des
commissions le débat s'est cristallisé
autour d' disposition qui a été
introduite il faut le rappeler par les
députés lors de la première lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale ce débat na donc
pas cette fois entre la majorité et
l'opposition c'est déjà quelque chose il
est entre l'une des assemblées et
l'autre conformément à la position déjà
défendue lors de la première lecture la
commission des Lois du Sénat réaffirme
aujourd'hui vient de le faire tout à
l'heure de la manière la plus
convaincante son attachement au maintien
de la délégation de vote je peux ne peut
que soutenir l'analyse faite par le
rapporteur elle est fondée sur des
arguments juridiques qui plus est
constitutionnel et le dossier fondé sur
des arguments de bon sens qu'on ne met
pas suffisamment en avant me semble-t-il
en effet le seul type de de scrutin pour
lequel il n'est pas autorisé de recourir
à la délégation de vote c'est la
procédure de
destitution du chef de l'État prévu à
l'article 68 de la Constitution on voit
bien alors qu'une telle interdiction est
rare surtout que parce qu'elle est prévu
par la Constitution prévoir une telle
interdiction dans un texte qui est de
nature organique poserait probablement
peut-être même à coup sû un problème de
constitutionnalité de plus les arguments
présentés par par nos collègues députés
à l'appui de cette interdiction ne sont
aucunement convaincants on nous dit
qu'un avis unique dès lors qu'il est
unique des deux assemblées ne pourrait
résulter de votes émis selon des
procédures distinctes cela reviendrait
je cite le propos du rapporteur à
l'Assemblée à fausser le sens de l'avis
recueilli et entacher ainsi la procédure
d'avis prévu par l'article 13 de la
constitution d'une vie d'un vis de forme
substantielle mais c'est allégation
n'est aucunement démontrée on n dit pas
en quoi il y aurait un visce de forme
car n lre de la Constitution ni les
travaux préparatoires de 58 de permettre
de penser qu'une procédure strictement
identique doit être retenue dans les
deux assemblées le constitoyen avait
laisser au règlement de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat la détermination
de ces dispositions conformément au
principe d'autonomie des deux assemblées
on voit pas la raison pour laquelle il
faudrait déroger au principe général à
l'occasion des nominations ce qui vaut
pour l'essentiel de la fonction
législative va bien valoir pour une
extension particulière et tout de même
relativement secondur de cette fonction
nous votons tous les jours des lois
selon des procédures qui ne sont pas les
mêmes dans les deux assemblées est ce
qui est voté quand même est àquis pour
avoir été voté dans chacune des
assemblées avec des procédures
différentes alors depuis quand faut-il
que les procédures soient identiques
c'est une manie d'uniformisation qui
malheureusement est typiquement
française et qui ne ti pas compte de la
diversité et deors qu'il y a deux
assemblées il est bien normal qu'il est
une certaine diversité C dans le cadre
naturellement de ce qu'autorise la
Constitution sur le fond je voudrais
faire la remarque suivante c'est qui me
paraît essentiel les éléments
d'appréciation dont nous disposons dans
une nomination ne se réduisent pas à la
breve confrontation parce que si je
comprends bien si on veut pas qu'il a
des délégations ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'on veut pas qu'il des gens
qui ont été absents qui aur été notre
aucune opinion personnelle sur le sujet
participe au vote je suppose que ça
dissimule ce genre de de d'accusation là
mais on se trompe parce que la procédure
actuelle les informations dont dispose
le parlementaire qui doit se prononcer
comprenn non seulement le les quelques
minutes d'audition qui relèv
éventuellement un peu du spectacle comme
on a pu le voir hier a l'après-midi ils
comprennent ah mais il y a d'excellents
spectacles très démonstratifs
naturellement et très
convainquant mais les éléments
d'information parentire comportent
l'ensemble des informations existante
que la presse ne manque pas de mettre en
lumière voire de révéler dès que le nom
du candidat sera connu ça n'a pas eu Liu
hier qu'il ne s'est passé que quelques
heures nous étions dans une situation
exceptionnelle mais d'une manière
habituelle il se passera non pas
quelques heures même pas quelques jours
peut-être même quelques semaines ou en
tout cas assez longtemps entre l'annonce
du nom et l'appartion de la Commission
de sorte que les commentaires ne
manqueront pas de se faire et que celui
qui doit participer à l'audition aura
déjà recueilli un certain nombre
d'informations sur le candidat ces
informations sont tout aussi pertinentes
sur sa vie son passé ses actions ses
œuvres éventuelles et cetera et donc la
connaissance du dossier est tout aussi
importante que l'effet produit par
quelques minutes d'audition j'ai même
tendance à penser que c'est plus
important et qu'on peut donc en parfaite
connaissance de fautes et parce qu'on a
des raisons de ne pas valables bien
entendu de ne pas être présent qu'on
peut donner une délégation et émettre
par cette voielà un vote tout à fait
respectable et tout à fait conforme au
principe de la démocratie et de la
responsabilité au demeurant il faut
rappeler avec le rapporteur que les
délégations ne sont ne seopèent pas
n'importe comment qu'elles sont soumises
à une procédure de contrôle systématique
que si elle constitu un droit ce droit
n'est pas sans limite il il a une
avOcatiOn à s'appliquer que dans des
hypothèses qui sont limit limitativement
énuméré par l'ordonnance organique de
novembre 58 pour finir et selon l'usage
je salue l'excellent travail réalisé par
le rapporteur qui est justifié
aujourd'hui plus encore que jamais il a
su rester ferme sur l'analyse défendue
par notre assemblée dès la première
lecture je souhaite que nous continuons
à défendre cette position qui me parmet
qui me paraît à la fois conforme au à
l'état du droit à la diversité des
assemblées et tout simplement au bon
sens merci monsieur le sénateur la
parole est à Monsieur Bernard frima pour
le groupe socialiste pour 16
minutes
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le
rapporteur ser dans l'intimité d'un
jeudi matin dernier jour avant une
suspension
parlementaire nous examinons en 2è
lecture la loi organique et la loi
ordinaire relative à l'article 13 c'est
la deè lecture règne sur ce débat ins
suspense que nous pouvons qualifier
d'étonnant il y aura-t-il une 3è lecture
une 4è lecture une 5è lecture est-ce que
nous allons aller là vers une tentative
d'inscription dans le
guinesbook d'un texte de loi et son
examen l'avenir nous le dira de toute
façon en manière en domaine de loi
organique je dirais il y a déjà un
record qui est en train de s'établir
c'est celui qui concerne la loi
organique qui exigeait la révision
constitutionnelle précédente à propos du
statut du chef de l'État je crois c'est
l'article 68 si ma mémoire est bonne je
parle sous le contrôle du rapporteur mon
avion nous avions essayé de progresser
on nous a expliqué que ça allait trop
vite et qu'il fallait encore du temps
pour réfléchir donc nous savons saluer
la lenteur de la
réflexion espérant que cette lenteur
s'accompagnera d'une profondeur
équivalente alors sur le sujet qui nous
retient aujourd'hui sur lequel nous
sommes déjà exprimés et sur lequel nous
aurons peut-être encore le privilège de
nous exprimer une nouvelle fois à cette
tribune je voudrais d'abord commencer en
rappelant je dirais la position du de
fond du groupe socialiste vous avez
monsieur le ministre vu
dans la procédure une des innovations
les plus marquantes de la
Constitution permettez-moi d'être d'un
avis
légèrement différent en considérant mais
vous connaissez notre position sur le
fond que si nous saluons ce qui
constitue indiscutablement un progrès
puisque le Parlement est
associé la manière dont il est
associé nous semble je dirais tellement
manqué de souffle on trouve sous la
plume de quelques constitutionnalistes
parler de temps en temps à propos de
cette procédure de consultation du
Parlement les uns parlent d'un faunet
les autres parlent d'un leur en tout
état de cause elle existe et Pierre
Fauchon est trop attaché à la loi pour
savoir qu'une fois que la Constitution
est votée elle s'impose à tout le monde
et que tout le monde doit la respecter
et qu'une fois que la loi est votée elle
s'impose à tout le monde et tout le
monde doit la respecter quelle qu' été
la position que nous ayons pu avoir dans
l'élaboration de la révision
constitutionnelle et de la loi nous nous
réjouissons chaque jour un peu plus de
la l'opposition que nous avons manifesté
à cette révision sur d'autres points
même sur ce point-là nous étions
d'accord et nous avions même trouvé je
dirais au sein du Sénat des positions
qui n'ont pas été finalement totalement
ratifié qui étai des des progrès donc
c'est un progrès mais c'est un progrès
insuffisant nous l'avons dit parce que
le vetau négatif des
3/5è nous semble un leure puisqueun
vetau négatif des 3/5è C permett une
approbation par 40 % d'une assemblée et
que jamais mais je demande qu'à être
démenti je j'ai le sentiment que une
majorité existant dans une assemblée sur
une nomination proposée par le président
de la publique ou par le président d'une
assemblée réunir 40 % d'avis favorable à
cette nomination appartient je dira une
banalité sinon ça signifierait un tel
conflit d'une assemblée avec son
Président ou d'une majorité avec le
parlementaire avec le président de la
République qu'on serait dans un autre
dans un autre schéma bon au demeurant on
est bien là sur des postes importants
vous le rappeliez monsieur le ministre
important pour la garantie des droits et
des libertés
ou pour la vie économique et sociale de
la nation
alors
les les nominations les plus marquantes
moi je n'irai pas jusque là je dirais
des nominations puisqu'il y a quand même
un décalage assez fort entre le nombre
d'emplois auquels le président de la
République nomme et nous avons pu vous
monsieur le ministre avoir les éléments
qui permettaient de l'apprécier on en a
finalement une cinquantaine et je
voudrais tout de suite vous poser une
question a posé aussi rapporteur à
propos de cette liste avant de venir sur
le différent et sur la loi
ordinaire la la question que je que je
voudrais vous poser vous avez fait
allusion à une ordonnance qui a modifié
la liste alors comme nous avons le
privilège d'être en avette on a pu
s'adapter mais il y a dans l'intitulé
des fonction qui figurent dans les
listes un certain nombre de ces
intitulés qui relève du domaine
réglementaire il relève pas du domaine
de la loi s'il y a changement s'il y a
modification au niveau du domaine
réglementaire que se passe-t-il est-ce
que parce qu'il y a une modification
réglementaire et que ça ne se trouve
donc plus dans la lettre de la liste le
Parlement n'a plus d'avis à émettre ou
alors est
que il y a à ce phénomène et à cette
question une solution je pense que
juridiquement la question existe et que
il faudra il faudra y apporter une
réponse bien sûr une modification
législative mais on s'aperçoit de la
lourdeur du phénomène al je vis rvenir
maintenant au différents qui existe
entre l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
sur le vote par délégation bon il me
semble effectivement en première analyse
que comme le vote par délégation est
expressément prévu par la Constitution
pour le vote d'une loi il semble pour le
moins difficile qu'il puisse être
interdit pour l'émission d'un avis d'un
simple avis dans le cadre d'une
commission je pense que le problème
nexisterait pas si nous avions créé
comme on avait un moment évoqué la au
niveau de la révision constitutionnelle
une commission ad hoc qui aurait été
paritaire entre le Parlement et le Sénat
et qui aurait misis un avis sur ces
nominations mais c'est pas le choix qui
a été fait alors que peut-on que peut-on
voir dans dans ce débat bon d'abord
constater un certain nombre d'évidences
juridiques comme je les ai signalé qui
permettent de de soutenir la position du
du rapporteur de plus reconnaiss que
l'utilisation d'une délégation a le
mérite de permettre de traduire la
réalité politique de l'assemblée qui
vote et d'éviter donc le fait de
majorité de circonstances mais d'un
autre côté je pense qu'il faut aussi
reconnaître que il est nettement mieux
et nous en fournissons la démonstration
ce matin il est nettement mieux que les
sénateurs ou les députés soient présents
à l'audition et puisse écouter celle ou
celui qui est susceptible d'être nommé
avant d'émettre un avis et donc je
dirais cet élément de présence est un
élément important et je crois que dans
la délégation vous permettrait de dire
qu'il faut aussi en voir la pratique et
je pense que il y a trop souvent une
tendance de
facilité dans l'utilisation des
délégations la délégation c'est un code
force majeure
or essentiellement c'est tout au moins
celui qui est invoqué de manière
systématique quand nous opérons des
délégations en commission au Sénat et on
a tous je dirais l'expérience de
souvenir de collègues absents pour cas
de force
majeur ouvrant tout d'un coup la porte
de la commission dont ils étaient
absents pour de force majeure pour
participer aux travaux et puis la force
majeure ' absenté au bout d'un quart
d'heure et à ce moment-là ils sont de
nouveau absents pour cas de force majeur
et la délégation peut être utilisée je
pense qu'il faudrait arrêter de
transformer les cas de forces majeures
en cas de force mineur et il faudrait
qu'on ait une éthique un peu plus poussé
de la délégation il faut peut-être en
parler dans le règlement mais je pense
que c'est beaucoup plus un problème de
pratique et
effectivement l'utilisation peut être
comprise expliqué mais je dirais il y a
un systématisme qui dévalorise la
délégation de vote et et dans la
pratique parlementaire c'est à mes yeux
tout à fait détestable au demeurant je
dirais mon groupe soutient la position
du rapporteur par un simple respect de
la Constitution je ne vois pas pourquoi
puisque la Constitution autorise le vote
par délégation une instruction d'un
bureau pourrait l'interd dire à propos
d'un avis et je souhaite parce que ça
dépend de nous bien sûr mais ça dépend
peut-être un peu plus de la majorité des
deux assemblées que vous trouviez un
accord je dirais et que vous réussissiez
à développer un minimum de confiance
mutuelle entre les deux groupes
majoritaires pour que les députés
membres de la commission anciennement
des affaires de comique de l'Assemblée
ne vivent plus dans la crainte de voir
leurs collègues de la majorité sénateur
s'opposer à eux bon enfin vous savez les
histoires de famille c'est toujours
difficile vous avez eu monsieur le
ministre l'intelligence de ne pas poser
le problème dans la loi et c'était très
bien je dirais nous n'avons fait mais je
vous rassure de ma part ce n'est qu'une
exception nous avons rejoint cette
position puisque nous revenons là à
l'absence de texte
initial sur la loi ordinaire sur la loi
ordinaire nous avions euh mon le
rapporteur indifférent il a été de fait
tranché par la
pratique contrairement à notre collègue
Pierre Fauchon nous avons souhaité que
les auditions soient publiques mes
collègues députés socialistes avaient
rajouté le terme audition lors de la
deuxème lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
nous avons souhaité que ces auditions
soi publi pourquoi parce que le
caractère public de l'audition je l'ai
dit hier quand nous écoutions uber nel
dans la première partie des deux
auditions que nous avons eu le caractère
public avec forcément la retransmission
par les chaînes parlementaires permett à
l'ensemble de nos citoyens de prendre
connaissance et donc d'une certaine
façon c'est une dans un réflexe
démocratique de
s'approprier les candidats et de pouvoir
avoir accès je dirais ne serait-ce que
le temps d'une audition à la
personnalité qui est nommée à une
responsabilité excessivement
importante et cela c'est très bien parce
que je doute que la majorité de nos
concitoyens puissent facilement après
une fois que ceci est nommé rencontrer
écouter discuter avec l'intéressé donc
ils peuvent avoir à la fois je dirais un
éclairage sur la personnalité et avoir
une liaison en direct non pas que la
liaison par les médias soit gênante
puisque j'ai cru voir dans la presse
d'hier de longues pages consacrées à
ceux qui allaient être nommé d'ailleurs
avec des différences de volume assez
impressionnantes entre les candidats qui
ne représentent pas forcément je dirais
l'importance euh de l'apport qu'ils font
plus tard mais euh je dirais il y a là
euh au niveau de cette audience publique
quelque chose qui était essentiel parce
que je ne voyais pas euh ceux qui
s'opposaient ce qui pouvaient s'opposer
quel était l'argument qui pouvait gêner
cet élément public je pense que chaque
fois que nous pouvons faire prendre
conscience de ce qu'est la vie
parlementaire nous pouvons faire tomber
des clichés et nous pouvons faire
prendre compte de la réalité du travail
des des parlementaires et voir que sur
ce plan B les interrogations qui ont été
faites alors évidemment hier nous avons
eu un système tronqué puisque ça ne
s'est pas traduit par un vote mais je
dirais cétait à mon avis le plus gros
progme parce que je pense que la
publicité de l'audition va être aussi un
des éléments qui va aider à la réflexion
de ceux qui nomme hein je dirais vous
vous souvenez on se souvient tous que
cigula avait nommé son
cheval à des hautes fonctions ça devrait
je dirais nous épargner ce genre de chos
hein il avait nommé son cheval sénateur
c'est pour ça que je qualifier de hautes
fonction hein mais nous ne savons pas
l'histoire ne nous dit pas si le cheval
de Caligula a accordé des décéations de
vote ça je dirais sur ce point-là il y a
des recherche historique importante à
faire que jepose certains d'entre nous
feront voilà ce que je voulaais vous
dire donc moi je me réjouis je me
réjouis qu'après l'avoir refusé la
majorité de la commission des lois et êt
accepté que la publicité de l'audition
la loi ordinaire se résumant à la
définition des commissions compétentes
et à à ces ajouts qui ont été faits sur
l'audition publique je dirais nous
n'avons pas de raison de nous opposer à
la loi ordinaire même si nous
maintiendrons notre abstention pour les
raisons de principe parce que le progrès
fait nous semble très insuffisant même
si c'est un progrès nous continuons à
nous abstenir sur la loi organique mes
chers collègues je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Monsieur Emer de
montesc pour le RD
vous avez demandé la parole non
mais alors après s'il vous plaît fin sé
vous avez la parole et vous
seul en fin de
séance
personnel les deux projets de loi dont
nous sommes aujourd'hui à nouveau saisis
constituent une avancée majeur pour
notre État de droit comme cela avait
déjà été évoqué en première lecture il
participe du fond du profond élan de
rénovation de nos institutions qui a
permis d'insuffler la révision
constitutionnelle de juillet 2008 des
pouvoirs rééquilibrés au profit d'un
parlement plus fort la nouvelle donne
institutionnelle àoué un droit de regard
renforcé de la représentation nationale
pour la nomination à certains des plus
hauts postes de la République les
auditions auxquelles ont procédit hier
notre commission des lois s'agissant des
futurs membres du Conseil
constitutionnel ont largement préfiguré
cette nouvelle donne dans l'attente de
la promulgation de ces deux textes les
autorités administratives indépendantes
ont pris nous le savons un essort
considérable dans notre paysage
institutionnel depuis une quinzaine
d'années à l'origine véritables objets
administratifs mal identifiés elles sont
désormais incontournables
leur champ de compétence s'élargit au
fur et à mesure que la loi en crée de
nouvelles au point qu'il est même
difficile de les recenser de façon
exhaustive
elle participe néanmoins de la
transformation de l'action publique en
s'ériigant à côté de l'État opérateur en
Vigi chargé de préserver l'intérêt
général en toute impartialité c'est
ainsi que sont concernés des domaines
aussi vitaux que la protection des
libertés fondamentales ou la régulation
économique la volonté de transparence et
l'approbation du Parlement guide ainsi
la nouvelle procédure de nomination et
je m'en félicite dans sa nouvelle
rédaction l'article 13 de la
Constitution opère une distinction entre
les emplois régaliens pour lesquels la
procédure en vigueur depuis 1958 sera
maintenue et ceux qui ont une importance
pour la garantie des droits et libertés
ou la vie économique et sociale de la
Nation pour lesquels la procédure
nouvelle rentre obligatoire une audition
pour la commission permanente compétente
de chaque assemblée suivie d'un vote
cette innovation permettra d'introduire
une réelle transparence dans les
procédures de nomination nos commissions
parlementaires devront ainsi vérifier la
compétence l'éthique et l'indépendance
des personnes proposées la publicité de
la procédure donnera aux auditions une
dimension national qui garantira la
crédibilité et l'autorité de la
personnalité finalement nommée mes chers
collègues les nominations à la
discrétion qui étit effectué sous
l'empire de l'ancien article 13 n'ont
pas honoré l'histoire de notre
République cette survivance du 19e
siècle a parfaitement su être utilisée
par les majorités successives à des fins
souvent peu en rapport avec le seul
intérêt général
notre pays a toujours refusé
l'instauration d'un spoil system à
l'américaine mais force est de constater
que l'opacité qui a présidé nombre de
ces nominations a joué en faveur de
l'émergence d'un état trop sauvent
partisan je me réjouis donc que la
nouvelle rédaction de l'article 13 mette
fin à ces abus l'importance des
fonctions concernées par le champ de la
loi organique justifie naturellement
cette transparence l'unification des
régimes de nomination disparate par ces
deux textes contribue à la clarification
de la procédure ceci a d'autant plus
d'importance qu'un certain nombre
d'autorités visées interviennent dans le
champ des libertés fondamentales pour
lequel le Parlement doit exercer
pleinement son rôle de protecteur et de
Vigi notre commission des lois peut
d'ailleurs revendiquer d'avoir encore
enrichi cette liste
sans que nos collègues députés n'y
trouve à redire d'autres regretteront
que certaines autorités n'ai pas été
incluse dans le périmètre de la loi
organique comme l'Agence française de
sécurité sanitaire des aliments l'Agence
française de sécurité sanitaire des
produits de santé la commission
consultative du secret de la défense
nationale ou la Commission nationale de
contrôle des interceptions de sécurité
mais s'agissant des deux dernières ces
deux autorités déjà d'un mode de
nomination spécifique destiné à
renforcer les garanties entourant les
nominations et qui se concilie très bien
avec la spécificité de leur champ de
compétence particulièrement sensible je
ne partage donc pas leur
inquiétude je regrette que ces deux
projets de loi nous reviennent en
seconde lecture en effet un des accords
subsiste entre nos deux assemblées à
l'article 3 sur l'interdiction rétablie
par l'Assemblée nationale des
délégations de vote lors d'un scrutin
destiné à recueillir l'avis d'une
commission sur un projet de nomination à
l'instard des collègues de mon groupe je
me range à la position de notre
commission des lois qui a maintenu la
suppression de cet article je considère
en effet que nos collègues députés ont
introduit en l'espèce un obitaire dictum
qui va au-delà des disposition de la
Constitution et qui en cours de ce fait
la censure du Conseil constitutionnel il
est de surcroit d'interprétation
constante y compris dans jurisprudence
du Conseil que les dispositions de
l'article 27 de la Constitution au terme
desquels la loi organique peut autoriser
exceptionnellement la délégation de vote
non' pas vocation à être utilisé pour
prévoir la délégation par type de
scrutin mais simplement pour prévoir les
cas d'empêchement pouvant frapper un
parlementaire nous soutiendrons par
conséquent cette suppression fort de
cette dernière remarque les membres du
RDSE confirmeront leur vote de la
première lecture en apportant
unanimement leur soutien à ce texte une
minorité
s'abstiendra merci monsieur le sénateur
la parole est à madame la Présidente
Nicole borvau Cohen seat pour le groupe
crcspg pour cette
minut
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers
collègues nous sommes effectivement en
2e lecture de projet de loi organique et
ordinaire relatif à l'application de du
5e alinéa de l'article 13 peut-être il y
aura-t-il d'autres
lectures on sait pas quand est-ce qu'on
arrivera à voter mais en tout cas bon on
est obligé de de se
répéter pour
s'expliquer mon groupe s'est opposé au
5e alinéa de l'article 13 en son temps
en effet celui-ci a sorti le pouvoir de
nomination du président de la République
de
l'avis des commissions parlementaires
permanentes de chaque assemblée cette
disposition est effectivement nouvelle
elle est présentée comme significative
des droits du Parlement ce qui n'est pas
notre avis donc je le confirme en effet
elle ne serait significative que si la
nomination et les nominations du
président de la République sont
nombreuses aux responsabilités les plus
importantes de l'État et des secteurs
économique dans lequel l'État intervient
donc ce pouvoir de nomination était en
quelque sorte partagé entre le Président
de la République et le Parlement
c'est-à-dire si le Parlement jouait un
rôle essentiel vous le savez nous sommes
hostiles à la présidentialisation de nos
institutions or il n'en est rien le
droit de vetau des commissions 35è de
leurs membres étant quasi impossible
dans le système politique qui est le
nôtre aujourd'hui sauf car rarissime par
contre l'audition des nominés donne
l'illusion d'un pouvoir du Parlement en
la matière ce qui est abusif il aurait
été nécessaire d'oser la démocratie et
de procéder à la consultation des
commissions réunies qui aurait pu se
prononcer à la majorité des 3/5e ce qui
aurait donné du sens à la vie du
Parlement vous l'avez refusé
nous ne pouvons donc par logique voter
contre les lois d'application de la
Constitution mais je voudrais dire quand
même puisque la question se pose sur la
question en suspend de la délégation de
vote nous sommes bien entendu favorables
à l'application de la possibilité de
délégation en cas de force
majeur puisque bien entendu il serait
regrettable que les parlementaires
manifestent qui ne s'intéresse pas aux
nominations et euh la délégation de vote
existant pour tous les votes sauf
d'institution du chef de l'État donc qui
compris la révision constitutionnelle la
position de l'Assemblée nationale et
difficilement difficilement soutenable
donc j'espère que la sagesse va finir
par l'emporter chez eux
euh concernant la loi ordinaire relatif
à l'application de l'article 56 de la
Constitution c'est-à-dire qui soumet les
nominations des membres du Conseil
constitutionnel à là aussi la vie des
commissions des lois du Parlement je
voudrais faire quelques commentaires en
premier lieu déplorer vraiment que pour
des raisons bien peu compréhensibles
pour le commun des mortels même si notre
traintrain parlementaire nous permet de
les comprendre il est regrettable que
nous soyons amenés à voter cette loi au
lendemain des auditions concernant trois
nouveaux membres du Conseil
constitutionnel leur nomination
effective devant intervenir d'ailleurs
plus tard je crois qu'il aurait été
vraiment utile de faire concorder les
deux puisque ça nous aurait évité un
simulacre de consultation en public
puisqu'il s'agissait d'une audition sans
effet aucun encore moins que les fait
normal mais je voudrais surtout insister
encore une fois sur le problème posé par
la composition et le mode de désignation
du Conseil constitutionnel alors que
celui-ci va être considérablement
renforcé dès le 1er mars puisqu'il se
transforme avec la nouvelle exception
d'inconstitutionnalité en véritable
juridiction de droit privé et de droit
publi pouvant de fait exercer sa tutelle
sur la Cour de cassation et le Conseil
d'État ainsi un organisme émanant
directement du pouvoir politique dans le
cadre d'un système présidentialiste où
la la majorité procède de l'élection
présidentielle et où le fait majoritaire
pousse à la
bipolarisation et bien ce donc ce
Conseil constitutionnel se trouve érigé
en une sorte de cour suprême cela pose
le problème de la séparation des
pouvoirs et cela pose de façon accrue la
question de la légitimité démocratique
du Conseil constitutionnel franchement
notre mode de désignation ne peut
perdurer longtemps les arguments
employer pour contourner cette question
ne sont pas convaincants le Conseil
constitutionnel doit être représentatif
du pluralisme politique de la
représentation nationale c'est-à-dire
des courants d'opinion il doit donc
procéder du Parlement je ne dis pas
composé de parlementaires et c'est
d'ailleurs assez amusant que précisément
soi nommé hier trois parlementaires
trois hommes je ne sais pas si le
Parlement avait eu un véritable pouvoir
s'il aurait osé N nommé trois hommes
parlementaires comme membres du Conseil
constitutionnel donc le peuple fait la
loi par ses représentants la loi et la
Constitution par ses représentants élus
l'organisme chargé du contrôle de
constitutionnalité non seulement ne
saurait émettre que des avis mais encore
il ne devrait pas pouvoir surreprésenter
tel ou telles opinions donc il n'y a pas
seulement lieu d'améliorer les
possibilités de se prononcer du
Parlement sur les nominations mais de
changer le mode de désignation et la
composition du Conseil constitutionnel
en étant courageux et en supprimant les
membres de droit les anciens Présidents
membres de droit donc je confirme notre
vote contre là aussi par logique de par
rapport à la la constitution de la loi
organique et de la loi ordinaire merci
merci madame la Présidente la parole est
à Monsieur Laurent
betteille pour
l'UMP madame le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues nous examinons en deè lecture
de texte qui constitu et je crois qu'il
faut le répéter un apport tout à fait
novateur et important de la révolusion
constitutionnelle du 23 juillet
2008 ainsi avec l'article 13 de la
Constitution et prévu que l'exercice du
pouvoir de nomination du président de la
République fera préalablement l'objet
pour certains emplois ou fonctions d'un
avis public des commissions compétentes
des deux assemblées sommes bien bien
entendu extrêmement favorable à cette
innovation et se pose assez vite
effectivement le problème de la
publicité des auditions sur lequel je
partage quelque peu à titre personnel en
tout cas l'opinion
de de Pierre Fauchon mais je dois dire
que après examen puisque nous avons eu
la chance hier de d'assister à l'examen
blanc euh qu'on subi nos collègues
uber Enel et et et Michel charas que
finalement les choses se passent de
manière tout à fait acceptable et même
si on pouvait imaginer un autre système
dans lequel on est un contre-rendu
intégral des des entretiens je crois que
au final la publicité totale et directe
n'est pas en soi gênant bien au
contraire cette audition permet ensuite
au Parlement de s'opposer à une
nomination du président de la République
lorsque l'addition des votes négatifs
des commissions représentera au moins
tr5è des suffrages exprimés alors j'ai
bien entendu un certain nombre de
réserves nous disant que le Président de
la République par conséquent pourrait
nommer quelqu'un qui n'aurait reçu
l'approbation de 40 %
des parlementaires concernés
permettez-moi de vous faire observer que
si c'est vrai en pratique pour autant je
ne peux pas imaginer qu'une nomination
intervienne dans ces conditions et et
personne ne peut croire que s'agissant
de postes comme par exemple le Médiateur
de la République il puisse être désigné
alors que il n'aurait reçu l'approbation
de 40 % des des parlementaires je pense
que ce serait aller à une
affaiblissement de la crédibilité de
l'institution et personne ne se livrera
à cela c'est dire que notre vote est
extrêmement important et même si on
laisse une marge d'appréciation au
président de la République dans cette
zone qui va de la majorité au au
35e j'estime que il y a une
force de de l'appréciation que nous
aurons donné qui sera dans certains cas
assez
irrésistible alors bien entendu sur le
même principe le président de
l'Assemblée nationale et celui du Sénat
ne pourront procéder aux nominations qui
relèvent leurs compétences à savoir
celle des membres du Conseil
constitutionnel et des personnalités
qualifiées membres du Conseil supérieur
de la magistrature lorsque de la même
façon les votes négatifs au sein de la
commission permanente compétente de
l'Assemblée conc représente au moins
3/5e des suffrages exprimés il va de
soit que ce que nous exp nous imposons à
l'exécutif nous devons nous l'appliquer
également cette nouvelle prérogative a
une double ambition vous le savez
d'abord assurer la transparence du choix
des personnalités appelé à exercer des
fonctions éminentes pour la garantie des
droits et des libertés et pour la vie
économique et sociale de la nation et
aussi de garantir l'indépendance des
candidats vis-à-vis du pouvoir exécutif
en encadrant de la manière que j'ai dite
la compétence du Président de la
République par ailleurs le constituant
confié au législateur organique le soin
d'arrêter une liste des emplois et
fonctions soumis à cette nouvelle
procédure et à l'initiative de notre
commission et sur proposition notre
excellent rapporteur cette liste a été
complétée à des fin
d'exhaustivité de même à l'initiative de
notre collègue Portelli la compétence de
la commission des lois pour donner
l'avis sur la nomination du Défenseur
des droits et des personnalités qualifié
membres du Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature et deuré d'avant
préciser le groupe UMP se félicite que
les
députés est adopté en seconde lecture le
texte ainsi opportunément complété par
notre
commission
cependant tout en retenant le principe
proposé par les députés de simultanéité
du dépouillement du scrutin portant sur
l'avis concernant les nominations c'est
à juste titre que la commission des lois
a une nouvelle fois supprimé l'article 3
du projet de loi
organique cet article que la l'Assemblée
nationale persiste à vouloir introduire
interdit les délégations de vote lors du
scrutin destiné à recueillir l'avis de
la commission compétente
or la fixation des modalités d'exercice
de la délégation de vote relève nous
semble-t-il clairement du domaine des
règlements du Sénat et de l'Assemblée
nationale et ni la lettre de la
Constitution ni les travaux
préparatoires ne permettent de penser
qu'une procédure strictement identique
et là je rejoins à nouveau pierre
Fauchon
décidément je je m'en excuse auprès lui
de le le paraphraser presque mais rien
n'indique qu'une procédure identique
doivent être retenu dans la les deux
assemblées pour prononcer l'avis prévu
par l'article 13 de la Constitution pas
plus que pour les textes que nous votons
quotidiennement cependant nous estimons
que le constituant a souhaité laisser au
règlement de l'Assemblée nationale et du
Sénat la détermination de ces
dispositions conformément au principe
d'autonomie des assemblées et nous
souhaitons vivement qu'un accord puisse
être trouvé
euh par les deux assemblée sur ce point
et je partage nous partageons les doutes
de notre rapporteur quant au caractère
constitutionnel de cette disposition et
en effet comme le montre le choix du
législateur organique en 1958 et
l'interprétation continue qui en étit
faite le dernier alinéat de l'article 27
de la Constitution n'a pas voé a
permetre d'interdire les délégations de
vote pour tel ou tel type de scrutin le
seul et unique scrutin pour lequel les
délégations de vote sont explicitement
proscrites par le constituant concerne
on l'a dit la destitution du chef de
l'État et c'est suffisamment
exceptionnel pour que cette disposition
le soit
aussi et je dois dire que à mon sens
privé de droit de vote celui qui a un
appachchement légitime alors je j'ai
bien entendu ce que nous disait Bernard
frima tout à l'heure sur la légitimité
des empêchements mais il n'empêche que
celui qui a effectivement un empêchement
légitime lui interdire de se prononcer
ne me paraît pas forcément une avancée
démocratique sous réserve donc de ces
observations le groupe UMP considère que
l'adoption de ces deux textes
d'application de la révision
constitutionnelle apporte une nouvelle
pierre à l'édifice de la République
irréprochable que souhaite notre chef de
l'État elle est je le répète une avancée
pour l'émerchance d'un parlement
revalorisé et participe au rééquilibrage
des institutions de la 5e République que
nous appelons de nos vœux et vous ne
serez pas surpris qu'au terme de cet
exposé je vous apprenne que le groupe
UMP votera pour les deux projets de loi
merci monsieur le
sénateur alors je rappelle qu'au terme
de l'article 48 alinéa 5 du règlement à
partir de la
de je pensais vous donner la parole à la
fin de la séance mais si vous le voulez
je je vous la donne
maintenant non non non on nengage pas
merci madame la Présidente c'est
simplement pour un point de précision
éviter une équivoque notre excellent
collègue frima a dit tout à l'heure
s'agissant de la publicité des des
réunions de la commission pour les pour
les auditions des des candidats aux
nomination que son avis était le
contraire contrairement à mon avis parce
que j'ai exprimé non pas un avis opposé
à cette publicité je tiens à dire j'ai
simplement exprimé des réserves et donc
notre avis sur le prés de publicité
n'est pas différent simplement
personnellement je ne suis pas sûr que
ça ne produise pas des effets
regrettables et n c'est donc seulement
sur ce point qu'il y a une légère
divergence entre mon excellent collègue
frima et
moi-même alors je rappelle qu'au terme
de l'article 48 alinéa 5 du règlement à
partir de la deème lecture au Sénat des
projets aux proposition de loi la
discussion des articles et des crédits
budgétaires est limité à ceux pour
lesquels les deux assemblées du
Parlement n'ont pas encore adopté un
texte ou un montant
identique nous abordons donc le projet
de loi
organique l'article 1er non modifié je
le mets au voix qui est pour article
1er qui est contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté article
qui pour il est supprimé hein il est
supprimé bon c'est tout l'article 3 qui
est également supprimé après l'article 3
nous avons un article additionnel avec
un amendement de monsieur le rapporteur
l'amendement numéro 1
il y avait pas de demande de parole hein
sur tout ça madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre c'est un amendement
qui a pour but de combler une lacune que
je n'aurais pas déposé si nous avions
réussi à avoir un texte commun avec
l'Assemblée nationale mais comme il y a
pas de texte commun avec l'Assemblée
nationale nous en profitons il y avait
un oubli dans la loi organique c'est
qu'on avait oublié de dire que les
personnalités auditionnées seulement par
le la commission temp de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat à la demande du
président de ces assemblées devait faire
l'objet d'un vote et que dans
l'hypothèse où ce vote serait négatif à
hauteur des 3/5e et bien ceement là on
pourrait pas procéder la nomination
c'est donc un parallélisme des formes
avec les nominations prononcées par le
Président de la République et bien nous
proposons la l'extension aux nominations
proposé par le seul président de
l'Assemblée nationale ou président du
Sénat avis du gouvern monsieur le
ministre madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les les sénateurs j'aurais
peut-être pu me me
contenter dans dans mon avis de dire
simplement que le gouvernement
naturellement s'agissant du
fonctionnement de vos assemblées s'en
remettait à la sagesse bien mais je
crois que il est important que puisse
figurer au journal au Journal officiel
des des faites et des arguments de droit
donc euh pour nous les articles 56 et 65
de la
Constitution prévoi que les nominations
concernées je cite sont soumises au seul
avis de la commission permanente
compétente de l'assemblée concernée fin
de citation cette formule comme les
travaux parlementaires de la révision
constitutionnelle semble indiquer que
s'agissant des membres nommés par les
présid président des assemblées seul est
possible un avis et non un droit de
vetau par ailleurs la Constitution
habilite seulement la loi organique a
fixé la liste des emplois et non à posé
des conditions aux nominations décidées
par les présidents des assemblées donc
voilà ce que je voulais apporter comme
commentaire mais bien évidemment comme
je l'ai dit le Gouvernement s'en remet à
la sagesse de votre assemblée sur une
question qui relève du fonctionnement
interne de l'Assemblée nationale et du
Sénat merci il y a-t-il des demandes
d'explication de vote il n'y en a pas
monsieur le Président yest
ouais monsieur le Président vous voyez
on pensait vraiment que la lecture
combinée de 56 et
65 indiquait que c'étataiit les mêmes
règles en matière de de désignation par
les seuls présidents des assemblées Mo à
partir du moment
où l'interprétation n'est pas celle-là
et on peut on peut enfin on peut en
douter franchement et d'ailleurs le
rapporteur le rapporteur de la révision
constitutionnelle est au regret de vous
dire qu'il n'avait pas réfléchi à cette
question précise sur les parce que
c'était à peu près secondaire dans le
l'ensemble des débats sur le à partir du
moment où c'est un avis effectivement et
qu' a pas d'interdiction
d'ailleurs depuis le début moi je dis
sauf si disait 3/5e positif ça veudrait
dire que c'est l'opposition qui décide
des nominations qui serait quand même
intéressant c'est le droit de vetto
serait retourné mais enfin moi c'est à
peu près comme la dissuasion nucléaire
les 35e en
fait monsieur le doien oui c'est ce que
vous nous avez
dit la question méritait d'être posée la
question méritait d'être posée alors je
laisse le soin au rapporteur de savoir
si il est bien intéressant qu'on a un
problème problme de d'interprétation de
la Constitution c'est peut-être pas la
peine d'aller chercher des que le
Conseil constitutionnel donne un coup à
gauche un coup à droite enfin je sais
pas
hein on
est moi je je je je
je l'interprétation du gouvernement me
fait douter de la pertinence de notre
position mais je n'en dis pas plus la
Commission a adopté donc je laisse ce
soin au rapporteur de confirmer ou non
sa position
oui monsieur le
rapporteur moi je pense que
l'interprétation que nous avons donné
initialement reste la bonne mais nous
sommes en navette donc nous serons
ouverts dans ce dans la navette à
discuter de ce point de vue on n' pas
terminé hein on aura encore au moins une
lecture ici donc je préfère qu'on le
mette au vote qu'on en discute à
l'Assemblée nationale et qu'au cours de
la commission mixte parit éventuelle et
bien on puisse en
discuter ça il y en aura une tout de
même le gouvernement dit voilà
exactement bon je pense que on peut on
peut négocier ce problème mais on le
vote cette
fois-ci pas d'autre pas de demande
d'explication de vote je mets au voix
l'amendement numéro 1 qui est
pour qui est contre
abstention il est adopté les autres
dispositions du projet de loi organique
ne font pas l'objet de la deè lecture je
vais donc mettre au voix l'ensemble du
projet de loi organique il y a-t-il des
demandes d'explication de vote monsieur
le Président frima vous avez la
parole merci madame la Présidente bon
pour confirmer ce que j'ai dit à la
tribune que le groupe socialiste
s'abstiendra et quand même pour revenir
d'un mot sur je dirais ce discours qui
nous est régulièrement servi et qui
consiste à dire il y a les 35è positifs
il faut avoir un 35è négatif mais toute
façon ça n'a pas d'importance parce que
s'il y a même simplement une majorité
simple et bien la nomination ne se fera
pas il y a simplement il simplement une
incohérence si vous
voulez pourquoi avoir mis dans la
Constitution un véau 3/5e négatif si
c'est pour dire mais ce véteau n'a
aucune importance quand on met une
majorité qualifiée ça a un sens alors
faisant une proposition de loi de
révision constitutionnelle on avait
proposé nous que cet avis soit émis à la
majorité simple si j'ai bonne mémoire on
nous a dit non non non non la majorité
simple c'est pas bien c'est pas
suffisant il faut verrouiller et arriver
à ce 35e négatif dont la fonction est
effectivement que sauf exception le
Parlement ne puisse jamais atteindre cet
obstacle mis par la Constitution donc
moi je veux bien mes chers collègues
vous qui avez voté la Constitution vous
passez votre temps à nous dire que sur
ce point ce qui est dans la Constitution
n'a aucune importance puisque de toute
façon même une majorité simple négative
suffirait et ferait un tel Tollet devant
une nomination alors je pense qu'il y a
là une une incohérence que la position
initiale aurait été défendue si la
marjité simple je comprendrai au j votre
propos ou alors c'est je dirais
l'hommage du vice à la vertu puisqueà ce
moment-là vous reconnaissez et ça me
semble effectivement assez proche de la
réalité vous commencez à reconnaître
l'ensemble point par point des méfits
contenus dans la révision
constitutionnelle et nous allons
assister régulièrement à des aveux
successifs et à de reconnaissance
d'erreur c'est un spectacle tout à fait
charmant auquel nous assistons avec un
intérêt non
dissimulé y a-t-il oui monsieur Fauchon
explication de
vote je voterai ces texte mais je ne
peux pas m'empêcher d'admirer l'abileté
avec laquelle monsieur fra explique que
globalement cette réforme
constitutionnelle il est bien content de
pas l'avoir voté mais il est encore plus
content qu'elle porte ses
fruits bien monsieur bteille
oui je voudrais pas prolonger
excessivement les débats mais sur ce qui
a été dit en ce qui concerne la majorité
des 35è je crois que nous avons pris la
bonne décision je crois qu'effectivement
il est bon qu'il y ait une limite à
partir de laquelle officiellement et de
manière
totalement imposer le président de la
République ne peut pas nommer mais je
pense qu'il est bon qu'il y ait une zone
pendant
la une zone dans laquelle on lui laisse
un pouvoir d'appréciation sur
effectivement la position du Parlement
et je crois qu'à partir du moment et et
nos collègues socialistes ont beaucoup
milité pour ça à partir du moment où les
auditions sont publiques à partir du
moment où on médiatise énormément la
position du du Parlement et bien moi je
suis effectivement convaincu que dans
cette zone où on laisse le président de
la République public choisir s'il
maintient sa proposition de nomination
ou pas on lui laisse la possibilité de
sauver la face qui est pas forcément
négatif mais en même temps on on fait en
sorte que cette nomination elle ne
puisse se faire que si effectivement il
y a une rencontre entre la position du
président de la République et celle du
Parlement bien Madame la
Présidente je je vous donnerai la parole
après si vous le permettez Monsieur le
Ministre hein vous aurez tout entendu
madame la
présidente madame la Présidente je vais
confirmer donc mon vote en logique avec
mon opposition à l'article 13 mais je
voudrais dire que médiatiser un
parlement qui en fait n'a pas le le
pouvoir en l'occurrence de faire
grand-chose c'est pas forcément
idéal d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
quelqu'un a dit je ne vais pas le citer
parce qu'il va peut-être demander la
parole donc je ne le citerai pas mais
que les par parlementaires ont tout
loisir de s'informer par la presse de ce
qui va se passer et des candidats sur
lequel on va lui demander de se
prononcer vous avouez que c'est quand
même un petit peu paradoxal de penser
que le parlement qui devrait jouer un
rôle dans la nomination de personnes qui
sont appelées à remplir de hautes
fonction pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens apprennent pas s'informment
par la presse de sur sur les personnes
sur lesquelles ils sont appelés à se
prononcer donc franchement je crois que
on se
serait vous vous seriez grandi en comme
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure osant
véritablement la démocratie et le
pouvoir du Parlement je voudrais ajouter
une chose
pour donc là aussi peut-être
paradoxalement soutenir notre rapporteur
sur le parallélisme des formes entre
les les auditions du candidat des
présidents de la République et ceux des
présidents des
assemblées je crois que la dire le
contraire en quelque sorte pose vraiment
un problème parce que on considérerait
que sur les nominations du président de
la République au Conseil constitutionnel
en quelque sorte le Parlement a droit de
se le droit de se prononcer mais que sur
les
nominations de de des présidents des
assemblées il ne pourrait pas se
prononcer c'est quand même je trouve
assez curieux donc je crois que de ce
point de vue les parlementaires
devraient être unanime pour soutenir le
parallélisme des formes qui me
paraissait quant à moi évident voilà
merci merci Monsieur le
Ministre une minute madame la Président
je voudrais rappeler l'esprit dans
lequel le le gouvernement s'inscrit pour
pour la discussion euh de de cette
partie du texte je crois qu'il faut se
remémorer ce que le président de la
République avait dit à l'occasion de la
campagne électorale pour les
présidentielles en
2007 lorsqu'il avait parlé de son
souhait de contribuer en tout cas à la
mise en place d'une démocratie de plus
en plus
irréprochable ce qu'il avait appelé la
démocratie irréprochable dans laquelle
il disait qu'il fallait absolument que
les nominations soient faites sur la
base des compétences et non de la
connivance et en fonction des positions
des uns et des autres c'est bien de cela
dont on parle si on parle d'un vote à la
majorité simple le risque je dis bien le
risque pourrait être euh d'une décision
partisane absolument
on parle après d'un vote à la majorité
des de tiers enfin ou dans dans ces eau
là mais d'un vote positif là ça veut
dire qu'on donne le droit de vetto à
l'opposition si on on est favorable au
système que le gouvernement a retenu et
que l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
ont bien voulu voter et bien moi je
trouve que quelque part on est dans une
position d'équilibre on évite les
écueils et les excès d'un côté et de
l'autre puisque pour parvenir à ce
résultat il faudra dépasser les limites
partisanes et donc ça signifie que on
c'est bien la compétence qui sera
l'élément déclencheur du vote dans un
sens ou dans l'autre du Parlement et
donc je trouve que ça devrait rassurer
et en tout cas de mon point de vue ça
illustre parfaitement
la volonté de transparence la volonté de
transparence qui est celle du
gouvernement et que les nomination ne
soit pas faite parce que sur des
critères qui soient partisans mais bien
sur des critères de compétence et
franchement ce que nous venons de vivre
depuis de à 3 jours me semble-t-il
illustre parfaitement cette volonté du
Président de la
République bien il n'y a plus apption de
vote je mets donc au voix l'ensemble du
projet de loi organique en application
de l'article
59 du règlement le scrutin public est de
droit il va donc être procédé dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
remettront au secrétaire un bulletin
blanc ceux qui souhaitent voter contre
remettrons au secrétaire un bulletin
bleu ceux qui souhaitent s'abstenir
remettront au secrétaire un bulletin
rouge le scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques
instants
bien le scrutin est
ouvert
absument
le scrutin est
clos j'invite Mesdames et Messieurs les
secrétaires à procéder au dépouillement
du
scrutin
voilà résultat du scrutin sur l'ensemble
du projet de loi organique relatif à
l'application du 5e alinéa de l'article
13 de la Constitution nombre de votants
339 nombre de suffrages exprimé
218 majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés 110 pour l'adoption
194 contre 24 le Sénat a
adopté nous passons maintenant à
l'examen du projet de loi
ordinaire et nous avons à l'article 1er
un amendement numéro 1 de Monsieur frima
I merci madame la Présidente on a déjà
eu l'occasion dans la discussion
générale de l'évoquer cet amendement euh
traduit et al sur un avis favorable de
la commission des lois hier et je dirais
une application pratique hier après-midi
c'est le caractère public des des
auditions je pense que c'était quelque
chose qu'il fallait faire et qui est
indispensable et maintenant que je
dirais dans la pratique les deux
assemblées l'ont utilisé il me semble
bien de le mettre dans la la loi surtout
que pour d'autres nominations il avait
déjà
été pris cette décision de le mettre
dans la loi je parle sous le contrôle de
mes collègues de la
commission de la culture
Hanco qui était de dire sur France
télévision et sur Radio France la
nomination des présidents de ces
sociétés fait à partir d'une audition
publique et il aura été mal venu que
nous ayons des traitements différents
pour telle nomination publique tel autre
pas publique ça mettra toutes les
auditions publiques je pense que c'est
un progrès j'ai bien entendu qu'il n'y
avait pas d'hostilité de la de la part
de pierrechon mais des réserves je pense
que le temps lèvera en toute sérénité
ses
réserves merci avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
madame la Présidente j'ai j'ai changé
d'avis entre la première lecture et et
la deuxième lecture au sein de la
commission parce que au départ je je
pensais que une audition à huclos
permettait d'aller plus au fond des
choses mais je me suis rangé à la
proposition de Monsieur FremAN ainsi que
la Commission et en effet je crois que
contenu du fait que un certain nombre
d'auditions sont publiques il y avait
pas de raison que d'autres soient soit
pas public qu'à l'Assemblée nationale
ils ont décidé que ce soit public il y
aura eu aucune raison qu'au Sénat ce
soit secret et public à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est la raison pour laquelle
je trouve que l'amendement de notre
collègue frima est un amendement
parfaitement justifié et la commission é
met un avis
favorable avis du gouvernement on va pas
critiquerendement le le gouvernement
dans cette affaire je le redis souhaite
que l'on s'inscrive totalement
sans retenu dans une démarche de
transparence ce qui veut dire que
naturellement l'audition publique
procède tout à fait de cette évolution
positive nous y sommes
favorable très favorable alors je
comprends bien que peut-être dans
certaines circonstances s'agissant de de
défense ou de choses comme ça certaines
exceptions puissent effectivement
intervenir elles sont d'ailleurs prévues
mais ce qu'il faut retenir c'est la
généralisation de l'audition publique de
toute façon j'ai envie de dire j'ai pas
oublié une vie politique antérieure à
mon entrée au gouvernement donc si vous
m'autoriser à y faire référence
simplement les fleurés je suis je pense
que ça fait partie d'un parlement
moderne que sauf encore une fois si
c'est nécessaire tout ce que le
Parlement fait soit public voilà merci
monsieur le ministre il y a-t-il des
demandes d'explication de vote je mets
au voix l'amendement numéro 1 avis
favorable donc qui est
pour donc j'ai même pas demandé qui est
contre il est adopté amendement numéro 2
monsieur
frima oui madame la Présidente cet
amendement numéro 2 devient presque sans
objet puisqueà partir du moment où il y
aura audition publique et au moment où
cette audition publique je dirais est
enregistré nous avons par la même un
contre-rendu je dirais qui dépasse la
simple écrit puisque nous Pons nous
pouvons voir les visages étonnés
admiratif soupçonneux en même temps ce
que ne traduit jamais un contre-rendu
écrit malgré le talent de ceux qui
l'écrivent et qui qui note de temps en
temps puisque ça arrive quelquefois
exclamation dans dans les rangs de tel
ou tel groupe là nous aurons l'image le
son et par définition nous aurons un
compteendu intégral donc il me semble
préférable de retirer cet amendement il
est retiré le numéro 3 c'est monsieur le
rapporteur gellard qui le
présente Madame la Présidente c'est
l'expérience des auditions que nous
avons mené hier et qui nous a amené à à
a pensé qu'il fallait prévoir un délai
entre le moment où le nom était proposé
et l'audition par la commission
travailler dans l'urgence en
annonçant les propositions la veille du
jour o on se réuni ou le matin même ce
n'est pas très souhaitable et c'est la
raison pour laquelle à l'origine j'avais
prévu 15 jours d'ailleurs mais 15 jours
c'était beaucoup trop long et donc le
président yes m'avait suggéré de ramener
à 8 jours on a ramené à 8 jours alors là
encore on est dans la navette par
conséquent c'est encore une disposition
qui peut-être améliorée le ministre
avait pensé qu'il serait peut-être
nécessaire d'envisager des cas
d'urgence on verra on verra dans la
navette je vous propose donc de faire en
sorte que cette audition ne peut avoir
lieu moins de 8 jours après que le nom
de la personne dont la nomination est
envisagée été rendue publique je crois
que c'est une sage précaution et par
conséquent je vous propose d'adopter cet
amendement avis du
gouvernement madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur d'abord je
voudrais
confirmer les propos du rapporteur me
concernant puisque je vais les je vais
les délivrer maintenant effectivement
concernant les les circonstances
éventuellement exceptionnelles qui
peuvent survenir moi je comprends
parfaitement la la préoccupation exprimé
par la commission ça me paraît bien
légitime je me permets quand même de
relever que ce qui s'est passé hier et
l'illustration que sans préparation et
sans délai les deux commissions des lois
de l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat
sont parvenus à effectuer un travail qui
fait honneur et à l'une et à l'autre
donc je crois vraiment que sur ce
plan-là il ne faut pas avoir de regret
nous n'avons aucune opposition de
principe sur le sur le le délai bon
est-ce qu'il faut l'inscrire dans la loi
je crois ce sera ma conclusion que la
question est en suspend et puis ça fera
l'objet de la poursuite de la réflexion
dans le cadre de la navette entre les
deux champs du Parlement donc le
Gouvernement émet un avis de
sagesse monsieur le
Président oui monsieur madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre si le
Sénat et l'Assemblée ont fait ont fait
quelquefis sa'ffire des démarche
acrobatique pour l'ordre du jour les
délais de et cetera ça doit pas devenir
la règle quand il va y avoir je ne sais
combien de de dizaines de nominations et
qui s'étal dans le temps mais la
commission de l'économie par exemple
quand on regarde sur les 41 bah qu'
sache qu'on puisse programmer les
auditions dans un délai raisonnable et
qu'on connaisse le nom parce que bien
entendu hier on peut dire bah oui les
les candidats connaissaient enfin savait
à peu près si serait disponible
l'après-midi les deux du Sénat c'était
assez évident donc c'était possible
d'organiser les auditions dans certains
cas monsieur le ministre s'il y a pas un
délai l'audition sera très difficile à
organiser et donc ça me paraît légitime
qu'on mette un délai pour connaître pour
organiser vous savez bien la difficulté
d'organisation de nos travaux pour tout
un tas de raisons monsieur le ministre
et donc vraiment je crois que c'est une
sage c'est une sage euh décision
d'obliger avoir 8 jours al dit l'urgence
et cetera il peut y avoir des cas non
parce qu'on peut toujours reporter une
audition il y a pas de nécessité
impérative généralement sauf peut-être
pour quelques organismes il y a pas de
nécessité impérative de procéder à
l'audition le jour où on l'a enfin il y
a pas de il y a pas de délai de
forclusion obligatoirement donc à partir
parce que si ben non
oui la date de renouvellement oui mais
attendez la date de renouvellement mais
je crois que certains organismes
franchement ils peuvent attendre 8 jours
hein l'Autorité de régulation de je ne
sais quel de de des activités portuaires
ouis c'est c'est c'est pas c'est pas
forcément indispensable qu'il soit nommé
le jour pile où c'est déjà arrivé
d'ailleurs dans le passé quand il y
avait pas de consultation qu'on ne nomme
pas exactement à la date à laquelle
finissait le mandat de celui qui sortait
donc je crois que tous les arguments
mais nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est quand
même d'avoir un délai pour pouvoir
organiser les auditions dans de bonnes
conditions et permettre à chacun de
notamment des membres des commissions
de pouvoir être présent sauf
empêchement prévu par la
Constitution madame la président borvoau
Cohen
seat non simplement je voulais dire ce
que vient de dire notre Président je
crois qu'il faut être sérieux parce que
on veut tous que la présence soit disons
quasi obligatoire sauf cas de force
majeur c'est évident que dans la durée
s'il y a pas de délai ce sera très
difficile à ob tenir et donc on en
arrivera à abuser des délégations ce qui
n'est enfin pas pas souhaitable donc
c'est c'est c'est tout à fait logique
d'avoir un
dél bien pas d'autre explication à
Monsieur
Fauchon comme c'est un amendement de
Fra je voudrais à mon tour dire combien
cette question de délai me paraît est
une évidence une évidence je permets de
dire monsieur le ministre je suis
surpris de vos réserves sur ce point il
n'y a pas de décision raisonnable qui ne
comporte un certain délai de réflexion
dans aucun domaine et qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'une décision un examen qui suit
de quelques heures la proposition euh
non seulement il y a les raisons
invoquées par Madame bvau on peut être
absent et mais surtout on peut avoir
besoin d'information on peut besoin de
réfléchir on nous a communiqué hier des
documents que nous n'avions pratiquement
pas seulement le temps de lire avant de
nous prononcer on peut poser des
questions il faut les préparer et comme
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure l'un des
grands avantages de cette réforme c'est
à mon avis c'est un avantage majeur
c'est que comme il s'écoule un certain
temps entre la proposition de
candidature et la décision on ne peut
pas surprendre la la Commission et elle
aura elle aura des informations la
presse jouera son rôle on saura des
choses et on saura à qui on a affaire
beaucoup plus et c'est de cette façon-là
que les exigence de la démocratie seront
le mieux satisfaites donc ce délai
surtout réduit à VI jour me paraît un
élé
essentiel de la qualité de la décision
alors je mets au voix l'amendement
numéro 3 qui est
pour contre il n'y en a pas il est
adopté à l'article 2 bis ah il n'y a pas
de
modification de teres non modifié donc
adopté les autes disposition du projet
de loi ne font pas l'objet de la deuxème
lecture je vais mettre au voie
l'ensemble du projet de loi il y a-t-il
des demandes d'explication de
vote il n'y en a pas donc je mets au
voix l'ensemble du projet de loi qui est
pour qui est
contre il est
adopté c'est la fin de cette séance pour
la revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité parlementaire cet après-midi
15h merci de votre fidélité très bonne
journée à tous sur Public
Sénat